i'm so excited to ask you about the big
reveal in the finale i'm just gonna i
want to just jump right into that so
first off
with max's big reveal at the end when
did you first find
out what was going to happen to him are
you getting scripts throughout the
season or did they give you that kind of
blueprint right at the start
so there's a lot of stuff that i find
out literally when we get the scripts
delivered i'm
quite literally the last to know very
grateful that i've known that i was
getting the power for a very long time
and i have not told
anybody i didn't even really tell the
cast i think jane knew
um of course but uh
it was something that austin told me
even before we started season two
um and it wasn't a question if it was a
question of when and it was a question
of
is the network gonna go for it and i
know that they had always gone for it
for it from its initial idea land
and pitch land and outline land but you
know things change and you know you get
the script and if the network or the
studio is like i'm not buying it it's
too soon
i'm not into it i was always really
worried that that could would happen so
i i i was more like hanging on to a
secret that i never fully believed until
we actually filmed it
and so um
[Music]
that was interesting for me because i
was just like is this really gonna
happen am i really gonna get the power
and when i actually saw it in writing
and the read-through then went well and
then i just got the next draft and it
was still in there
and then we was actually the data film
and i'm like i'm getting the power i'm
so excited
and then once jane started learning i'll
melt with you you know it was
it was weird the wheels were turning
even when it's
not official 100 happening but you were
aware that it that it likely will or
that austin wants it to happen
that moment when you learn about it does
it i guess does it still
influence the character at all kind of
knowing that that's
the road map i loved
i loved hitting home the theme
with zoe and max that there's this power
and balance
and that it's so unfair that you could
know what's going on in my head and i
have no way
when people re-watch episode season two
that is gonna come that comes up a lot
like it even comes up in passing like in
that scene that i was talking about in
our other interview
where i was freezing and and trying to
talk to her about when she was
kind of engaging with simon and i say
like hey that always messed with me the
fact that you could hear my thoughts and
i couldn't like i don't know
i don't know if that's helpful for a
relationship
um and it was really something that he
had to get over
uh and now it's something that he has to
completely cope with
and and it's a blessing and a curse as
we've seen for zoe so now that max says
it as well
um it might it might get interesting
moving forward
i was going back after i learned that
big finish there and i
i found it peppered all throughout the
season like you said but i just
like i couldn't believe how when it
actually happened the first time i
watched the finale what it what a shock
it was
i just like why didn't i think that that
was ever going to happen
i know it's something that's right in
front of your face but you never
expect it and that's why i really wanted
people to
watch the finale live and it's kind of a
community viewing thing because it's
like we're going to do something we're
going to
everyone thinks it's like t-max or team
simon what's going to happen and who's
she going to choose and
it's like hey there's other things that
are going to happen that are going to
like another kind of cliffhanger it's
not it doesn't end with max on the plane
and like is he gonna
is he gonna go or not like we've solved
that we're moving forward with that
but now here's another wrench in the
game speaking of the plane stuff
so one moment we don't get to see in the
finale is the conversation that max has
with rose
do you just to get in his head space and
to connect the dots between you know the
scene before and then the final scene
with zoe do you need to at least flash
that moment out and figure out how that
conversation happened for you
yeah kaylee finlay and i met actually
off off work and we just did an improv
of what that conversation i'm kidding
can you imagine that would be so
adorable wait by the way by the way
katie would actually be so
down by the way i'm sure if katie's
watching this interview she'd be like
why didn't we do that that'd been so fun
um she's an absolute delight to work
with and is so great
playing rose and i mean i i think that
it's it's it's kind of covered as far as
what that what that conversation would
go
like and he says in his scene with zoe
that you know she could tell
i had someone else on my mind and it
wasn't fair to her or
me or anyone involved and i agree
i mean i think rose is like an
unbelievable person it was actually
really good for max so
i think that scene in the kitchen and
the finale really just changes things
um it's always zoe's always been max's
first love
and there was always just something
keeping them apart and
i didn't know if max was ever going to
get that uh
from from zoe and james does such an
unbelievable job
throughout the whole episode throughout
the whole series and season but like
especially throughout the finale of just
like that's a tough thing that's a lot
of ground to cover for an actor
um to have a breakup and have these
thoughts and i buy it
i watched it i buy it hook line and
sinker i think they're
actually set up for success there's
something
extra special more meaningful and more
believable about it
that that decision happened before the
reveal of the power too
it's like i was trying to play through
what it would be like if it was reversed
and one came before the other and
i i don't know there might be too many
holes in the equation
or or too many uh too many question
marks there
i agree i mean it's like there's a
finality to
i hate saying her choice or her decision
because no none of us
team max team simon team zoe team rose
no one's like prize or anything like
that but
something that was holding her back and
something that she was never even able
to say in that kitchen scene at maximo
just don't go and
having peter kind of hit the nail the
coffin is so is so important for zoe's
journey i think
for her to just know unequivocally like
this is the right man for me and i'd be
foolish to let him go
and then on top of that she says it from
her heart
and then something that she can't fake
some is a heart song
all of our characters we can't hide what
we're feeling it's our full subconscious
so if audiences were ever like i don't
know so he really means that i don't so
he really wants it i don't know if so he
um should be with max if she's not ready
the heart doesn't lie
and so the fact that we got the window
into that
i think is actually a really important
device for the audience and for max to
know like this is for real
what do you know i assume there's no
season three scripts yet so
again do you have the blueprint of what
austin's hoping to do moving forward
i have a vague idea
you know what i have i have more his i
have more
my conversations with him that i do
the talking and he goes that's
interesting yeah i like it all
you know and then he takes it to his
genius factory and like marinates on it
i think also like
he likes to keep a couple things close
to his vest and i'm not kind of an
opportunist who wants to like know
for knowing sake i just like to kind of
have those nerdy conversations
i think that there is personally
where likes area that we could cover now
that max is the power
really says something about like what if
i hear a song
from somebody and zoe hears a completely
other song from that person
and what does that say about certain
constructs
what does that say about relationships
about listening
there's just so many i love when our
show gets cerebral and when we delve
into the power because it just says a
lot about human nature through this
really cool device
and now the two people harness it you
could even say more it just opens
so much more you kind of clarified one
other question i had and
and i think that i got the sense that it
was this this one way where both of you
have the power so it's definitely not
that the power was transferred from one
to the other
that i don't know actually that i'm
assuming just like you probably are i
mean
again that's something that like i've
mentioned to austin
and i don't know like and by the way i'm
not gonna now just start like revealing
completely how the sausage is made but
just to give you like three
full universes um
for season three i could personally and
i don't know
the answer to this i could see a world
where max only has it
i could see a world where they both have
it i could also see a world where
max only has it and then zoe gets it
back and then they both have it and then
only back and they're fighting over it
you know what i mean like and now
actually zoe when she thought that she
never wanted this power was running away
misses it and needs it back
and it's actually her search for the
power and she now presents max ford
like there's so many areas to go and you
could actually kind of do
a mixture of all of them or none of them
um and that is above my pay grade that
is not my job
but um i care so much and like i love
playing
those kinds of stories out so i'm i'm
really interested to see where this
series goes
you you make me feel a lot better about
my mind spinning out of control with the
possibility oh yeah yeah
and you know it just speaks to you guys
caring so much about the product here
and also
just how utterly engaging it is and
after two seasons i just i
deeply care about all of these
characters and need to know everything
that's going to happen to them
this might be another seemingly silly
question but
before max breaks it off with rose how
far
into the airport do they get i was just
curious if he went through security
we were curbside checking in when we
when we were doing the
when a man loves a woman's song i i know
i'm so you and i are so similar probably
when we watch shows because it's so
logistical
it's content there's continuity issues
there's like
i'm just did his bad get lost did he
have to like say goodbye
she gets on the plane and he awaits a
baggage claim for his own thing
did he have to get his bag shipped back
like how did that work i'd say just for
my own neuroses as skyler
like he didn't get through security not
to put you on the spot that's not where
my mind was going but that probably
would have been the next step because i
am like a little nutty when it comes to
lost baggage and it not transferring
over the right plane
the question came from did he go through
security and there was a glitch in the
machine like there was a glitch in the
mr
mri machine or like what what is the
thing
that gave him the power is it their
connection or a piece of technology
well great question we haven't gone into
it i only can assume
it's not radioactive um
because i i believe in
um in that dream having a lot to do with
the transfer
uh with mitch and i think the
affirmation of mitch being the person
that she's always looking up and
questioning to the universe
i always believe that the power not only
came from the mri machine but it was
also a coping mechanism
obviously and i know jane believes that
it really has to do so much with her
father so bringing back
that kind of almost god-like figure now
with peter i think is really useful a
cool device
and i think it has to do with that i
think it has to do with maybe her fully
letting go and her fully being
vulnerable
who knows if we start season three with
the damn x-ray machine
bring katie finlay back and i'm checking
in and i you know this is it
i have no idea i i again like i'm an
audience member when it comes to that
i only know as much as we're given and
uh everything you saw i mean
we're up to date now you and i and the
audience this is the kind of stuff that
i absolutely love thinking about though
same i got one more for you here and
again this might sound kind of silly but
now that you might be heading towards
having to do more of this in the show
what do you find more challenging being
a part of one of the big elaborate
heart song set pieces or having to be
the observer in one of those
well i've only been the observer twice
and i'm yours
and now i'll melt with you and i i
love i love how jane
plays all of her stuff and i'm
interested as an actor to kind of like
delve into that and what it means to
have a relationship because i truly
believe and i've said this before that
like
every song we've ever done on the show
is a duet
because jane is just as much a part as
those songs as
um the person singing it so i'm
interested i'm excited to kind of get
into the theory
the way jane does um about why this is
happening and why she's hearing this
song at this time um
something that i really love doing that
i probably won't be able to do
or maybe we could again we don't know is
what i did in don't stop me now
and jealous where i'm literally
stretching and doing quad stretches
while there's an
entire flash you know the group number
happening around me
those are actually my favorite because
i'm not engaged in what's happening
i'm not the one singing i'm just some
guy who has no clue that things are
going on around me
that's like my favorite thing to play
because i get to play against the moment
which is fun
um but i'm real i i'm so excited like
about the challenges and the rewards of
be having a front row seat and and
receiving it
and being active in those scenes as well
so um
i get the best of all worlds i'm very
lucky i am so pumped
for you guys like even just like sitting
here theorizing for a little is getting
me so hyped for
what's to come but gotta celebrate
season two and
i cannot congratulate you and the team
enough i hope
i mean everybody who's with us at this
point has watched it and they know how
special the show
is but just in case everybody out there
has someone else in their lives that has
have not seen any of the show make sure
you tell them like
what is wrong with you it's all
streaming on hulu and it
is just so utterly heartwarming
delightful the complete package i would
be shocked if anybody out there pushed
play and didn't have
a massive smile on their face and walk
away with their heartful so
hopefully that's enough of an
endorsement to get you guys to talk
about it even more
skylar i meant everything i said huge
congratulations
i love the show i appreciate it thank
you so much for having me